Let us look at the first, the model
base method for adapting our case.
Once again we're in this micro world.
Let us suppose that we
begin from our office, and
we need to go to a restaurant.
Given the problem of going from the
office to the restaurant, let us suppose
that we retrieve from memory a case
that takes us to a doctor's office,
which is quite close to the restaurant
but not the same as the restaurant.
So one way in which I might be able to
allot this case that I have received
to address the problem going from
the office to the restaurant,
is to do a search using this model,
this map of the world, which tells me
that to go from the doctor's office to
the restaurant office,
you can take this particular route.
So now, I have the earlier case,
which I've adapted,
using some model of the world.
This is an example of using
models In order to adapt cases.
>> So in my programming example earlier,
instead of having a map of the world,
we might have for example an API for
interacting with a particular language.
I've done input from a file in
Python several hundred times, but
I've never done it in Java before.
I know that the overall
process of doing in from Java
is going to be very similar to
the process of doing it in Python.
And I have a model of the way Java
works, to know how to actually translate
my case of doing in it in
Python to doing it in Java.
>> Good example David.
It is another one.
This one is from design.
When we design with
this kind of product,
let's suppose a VLSI circuit for
example, than we not only know something
about the configuration of
the elements in the design, we also
have a model of how that particular
configuration is supposed to work.
In fact, it might amuse you, David,
that about 25 years back in the 80s,
when I wrote my PhD dissertation, it was
one of the first PhD dissertations that
integrated model-based spacing and
case-based spacing.
That was exactly the idea
in my PhD dissertation.
You used models to be able to adapt,
evaluate, and store cases.